90 percent of all land plants
need to have aplant-fungus-root association.
You can see the fungus, which exists
in most of its life as thinfilaments,
and the network of thin filaments,
we call it mycelium.
And the mycelium of thefungus
can tap into the root of plants
and make a symbiosis.
And thereby, they exchangenutrients that
the other one isn't so good at making
or capturing.
But it doesn’t stopthere,
because the fungi can tap into
other plants at the same time,
So what you end up with is this
massive underground network
mediated by fungi.
Now, it's not just nutrients that are flowing,
but also communication,
because plants can talk to each
other through the fungal network
to create chemical signals tobe able
to warn of a pest attack, for example.